KILLED FOR BEING GAY AND
LESBIAN.
WOMEN THAT ARE TREATED
HORRIBLY.
THEY CAN BE FREE OF THESE
RADICAL DICTATORS.
JOINING US NOW, REACTION OF
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" BEST
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR NEWT
GINGRICH IS WITH US.
MR. SPEAKER, WELCOME BACK
AND HAPPY NEW YEAR, SIR.
GREAT YEAR.
>> Sean: SO YOU ARE WRITING,
I THINK IT WAS THE MOST
VIEWED ON FOX NEWS DOUBT FOXNEWS
VIEWED ON FOX NEWS DOUBT FOXNEWC
VIEWED ON FOX NEWS DOUBT FOXNEWM
VIEWED ON FOX NEWS DOUBT FOXNEW.
UNDER ESTIMATE AT YOUR OWN
PERIL AND 2018 GET READY FOR
THE POLITICAL SURPRISE OF
2018.
BECAUSE I'M WATCHING AND
LISTENING TO EVERYONE ELSE
IN THE MEDIA, THEY THINK
REPUBLICANS THAT WE HAVE
EVER SEEN.
I KEEP TRYING TO REMIND
PEOPLE ALL THESE PEOPLE
PEOPLE WRONG IN 2015 ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT TRUMP COULD
BE A CANDIDATE.
THEY WERE WRONG IN 2016
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT HE
COULD WIN THE NOMINATION.
THEY WERE WRONG IN THE FALL
THEY HAVE BEEN WRONG FOR ALL
OF 2017.
SO I START WITH THE IDEA I
LISTEN TO THEM CAREFULLY,
TIME I'M DOING BETTER THAN
THEY ARE.
AND I THINK THIS IS GOING TO
BE A GOOD YEAR.
I THINK THE TAX CUT BILL IS
SO CENTRAL TO THE FUTURE OF
AMERICA AND FLOIF BEHIND IT
OF LOWER TAXES MORE TAKE
HOME PAY.
MORE JOB CREATION, BETTER
BUSINESS ENVIRONMENT SO
CENTRAL TO WHAT MAKES
AMERICA TICK.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS WHO
UNANIMOUSLY VOTED NO.
THINK ABOUT THAT SEAN, THEY
UNANIMOUSLY VOTED FOR HIGHER
TAXES, BIGGER BUREAUCRACY,
YOU ARE GOING TO BE OUT OF
WORK BUT WE WILL GET YOU
FOOD STAMPS.
I THINK THAT'S A LOSING
PROPOSITION.
>> Sean: SO, ASSUMING THAT
COLLUSION AND COMING UP WITH
UNRELATED CHARGES FOR PAUL
MANAFORT, GENERAL FLYNN
LYING TO THE FBI, WE NOW
FIND OURSELVES IN A POSITION
AND WE WILL GET INTO THIS IN
GREAT DETAIL WHERE THERE ARE
ISSUES ABOUT COLLUSION.
THAT WOULD BE HILLARY
FUNDING THE DOSSIER PAID FOR
WITH RUSSIAN LIES,
MISINFORMATION, PROPAGANDA,
ALL TO INFLUENCE AN
ELECTION.
SHOULD THAT BE A BIG ISSUE
OR COMEY AND PETER STRZOK
WRITING AN EXONERATION
WHY WOULD ANYONE HAVE EVER
ALLOWED 20% OF AMERICA'S
URANIUM TO GO TO VLADIMIR
PUTIN, ESPECIALLY KNOWING
ABOUT BRIBERY EXTORTION KICK
BACKS AND MONEY LAUNDERING,
YOU KNOW, A YEAR AND A HALF
EARLIER?
ROBERT MUELLER KNEW ABOUT
IT.
SO, DO THE REPUBLICANS --
DOES THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
HAVE AN OBLIGATION NOW TO GO
AFTER WHAT WE DID FIND AS A
RESULT OF THE INVESTIGATION
THAT THE DEMOCRATS NEVER
REALLY EXPECTED TO FIND?
I DON'T THINK IT'S JUST
ABOUT REPUBLICANS OR
THE RULE OF LAW PROTECTS THE
WEAK FROM THE STRONG.
IT'S THE RULE OF LAW THAT
PROTECTS THE WEAK FROM THE
RICH.
IT PROTECTS THEM FROM THEIR
GOVERNMENT.
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION AS
AMERICANS TO WANT TO KNOW
WHETHER OR NOT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAD BEEN
CORRUPTED SENIOR LEADERS OF
THE FBI HAD BEEN CRIEWNTED.
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
FIND OUT WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WERE PUTTING IN POSITION OF
COULDN'T POSSIBLY BE PART OF
A DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THEY HAD TO BE A PART OF A
DEPARTMENT THAT WAS GOING TO
GO AFTER AND PERSECUTE
PEOPLE.
AND I THINK THAT WELL, HAVE
YOU RAISED IS THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO FIND
OUT DURING THE COURSE OF
THIS YEAR ABOUT A GREAT DEAL
OF MISMANAGEMENT AND
INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR IN
THE PHISH AND THE
THE FHISH AND THE
THE FBISH AND THE
THE FBI A AND THE
THE FBI ANDND THE
THE FBI AND T THE
THE FBI AND THEHE
>> AND THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
WE WILL GO BACK AND LEARN A
GREAT DEAL MORE ABOUT THE
CORRUPTION INHERENT IN THE
ENTIRE INVESTIGATION OF
HILLARY.
SO I DON'T SEE HOW YOU CAN
WALK OFF.
IT'S NOT A QUESTION ABOUT
VENDETTA AGAINST A PERSON.
HOW DO YOU HAVE THIS SCALE
SCANDAL AND JUST WALK OFF
AND FORGET IT?
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT'S JUST
HAPPENED LAST WEEK.
WE LEARNED THAT HUMA ABEDIN
HAD AN ADDITIONAL SET OF
EMAILS, AT LEAST FOUR OF
WHICH WERE WERE CLASSIFIED.
>> Sean: AND PASSWORDS.
>> ON HER HUSBAND'S LAPTOP.
>> Sean: PASSWORDS.
UNBELIEVABLE.
ALL RIGHT.
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT IRAN.
FOUR MONTHS AGO, WHEN THE
PRESIDENT WAS SPEAKING AT
THE UNITED NATIONS, HE
PREDICTED THERE WOULD BE
PREDICTED THERE TOULD BE
PREDICTED THERE THELD BE
PEOPLE WOULD REVOLT.
NOW WE HAVE IRANIAN
PROTESTERS ATTACKING POLICE
STATIONS.
THEY STORMED AN IRANIAN
MILITARY BALSZ ACCORDING TO
REPORTS.
AND THEY ARE CHANTING DEATH
GREEN MOVEMENT IN 2009, NOW
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT
SUPPORTING THOSE PEOPLE THAT
WANT LIBERTY, FREEDOM, MAYBE
EVEN CONSTITUTIONAL
GOVERNMENT.
IF YOU ARE THE PRESIDENT,
WHAT DO YOU DO NOW TO HELP
THOSE PROTESTERS.
>> FIRST OF ALL MINUS LETTER
TOMORROW IS GOING TO BE
PRESIDENT TRUMP, IRAN AND
LEADING FROM THE FRONT, THE
OPPOSITE OF OBAMA'S FAMOUS
LEADING FROM THE REAR
OBLIGATION TO, FIRST OF ALL,
MAXIMIZE THE PRODUCTION OF
GATHERING UP AND I
UNDERSTAND FROM AMBASSADOR
HALEY THAT THEY ARE LIKELY
TO ASK FOR UNITED NATIONS
SECURITY COUNCIL MEETING ON
THIS ISSUE.
I THINK WE SHOULD BE PUTTING
REAL PRESSURE ON THE
EUROPEANS.
THEY ARE ALWAYS PYES ABOUT
HUMAN RIGHTS.
HERE IS A CHANCE TO STAND UP
DONE TO HIS CREDIT ISSUING
VERY STRONG WARNINGS AGAINST
THE IRAN ONDICTATORSHIP
KILLING ITS OWN CITIZENS.
HOUSE AND SENATE WILL PASS
VERY STRONG RESOLUTIONS
CONDEMNING THE DICTATORSHIP.
IS IMPOSSIBLE TO BELIEVE
THOUGHT DICTATORSHIP IS A
POPULAR GOVERNMENT.
NOW, THIS IS A REPRESSIVE,
BRUTAL DICTATORSHIP, IT
I AM AFRAID THAT THEY ARE
PREPARED TO COME BACK AND
KILL A LOT OF PEOPLE.
WE SHOULD BE VERY